what are your impressions when you you
rolled into vegas and you've seen the
atmosphere and the and the feelings and
the the vibe of vegas well the first
thing you you know you land you're
you're on the strip right so you know
for a kid from canada that you know
didn't really spend much time here that
you know you see the people and
everything bright lights and all that's
going on and then you walk to the i like
to walk to the hotel where i walk to the
rink and there's i wouldn't call it like
tailgating specifically but there's
stuff going on outside the arena so you
can see that the fans are into it the
electric sort of atmosphere and
and then once you get in the first
couple times the
the pre-game show we're all watching it
and i just tell it's it's it's it's
quite a vibe in here now what i'm
starting to experience is get away from
sort of get outside of that get out here
and now you're seeing a different part
of you know
truly probably the communities etc
outside of sort of that
that that strip and and it that's real
appealing to me you know i like i said i
have a young family and i you want to be
part of a community and and
so that's the part i'm going to get to
know even more in the next couple days
that really excites us